i want to actually surprise her
and actually just call her she has no
idea so hopefully it's a good surprise
[Music]
hi
all right y'all um it is the season to
be thankful and i am very thankful for
all my fans for the past 20 years
whether you've come out to you know my
shows on tour or bought my music or
watched the voice and voted team kelly
or watched the kelly clarkson show
whatever it is thank you so much and i
wanted to celebrate by answering some of
y'all's questions so fans sent in a
bunch of questions um and i haven't seen
them yet so let's see how this goes
okay you are adorable let's get this
going hi kelly
can you tell us what's your name and
where you're from i'm from naked
i'm from texas and i'm making
nico how old are you five
nico who do you choose as your coach on
the boys kylie because she's beautiful
she's smart she's accident she's pretty
she's good
you really like kelly huh what is your
question that you would like kelly to
answer
what's your favorite put on what's your
favorite snack
oh my gosh nico i'm trying not to cry
because i just had my
makeup touched up you are freaking
awesome thank you for all the
compliments and also thank you for
loving team kelly on the voice
i would say my favorite food is i mean
you said you're from texas nico so
queso and chips are pretty up there on
my list that's probably my favorite
snack as well
i love chips in case i could just just
cheese is awesome
might not be great for you but it is
good for your soul as far as i'm
concerned and i just love chips and
queso mikko
okay here we go this is chrissy wait
where are we hi kelly my name is chrissy
carr i am from gallatin tennessee and i
am a teacher here i actually own a
preschool now i open this preschool to
help kids get the start that they need
for the rigor that's in schools right
now so we've been here for seven years
and it's working so we just want to keep
on going and giving those kids what they
need to be ready for school
so everybody knows my love for you not
only my kids get to hear you and they
know who you are and they're boys and
they appreciate kelly um but i also use
it in my classroom as well for a lot of
things so thank you for being there for
me through those ups and downs kelly
i've got two questions for you the first
one is how do you stay humble and how do
you apply that or teach that to your
kids to stay humble when they know that
their mom is the
kelly clarkson and then also
after you became a mother how has your
songwriting changed oh those are those
are good questions christy by the way i
said a farm in lebanon which is right by
gallatin tennessee it was actually kind
of on the line anyway um love tennessee
it's beautiful where you live
and it's really cool what you're doing
to prep those kids for school um there
were two questions one was how has it
changed my writing style as a mother i
do think like having something literally
in your body for nine months and then
and then it you know you bringing it to
life like that's a crazy thing to go
through
so i do think it has impacted me maybe
perspective wise you know you have to be
pretty selfless to be a parent i think
that's definitely probably changed me a
bit but other than that i mean i you
know i still go through all the same
emotions everybody else does if you know
you have kids you know kids it's we're
all humans and you know at our core we
all want to be loved accepted and
respected and do that for others as well
so still that that same kind of vibe is
there but how do i stay humble i you
know i've gotten this question literally
my entire career i don't even know how
to describe it so i just see myself as
super normal and i think most people
even if you know me as a celebrity i'm
pretty normal like whatever that means
whatever normal is and what i mean by
that is like i don't like there the
question i always get is like who's
famous in your phone i don't have a lot
of famous people on my phone like i have
like
my friends and my like my normal
i don't know when it comes to like
keeping my kids humble as well that's
hard for anybody y'all it's like kids
it's you know there's these egocentric
stages where you're trying to get
through and you feel like you're failing
and then they do something really
incredibly cool and sweet and kind and
you're like oh wait they heard me um but
then you know it's a roller coaster
isn't it um so there will be other
moments but thank you so much chrissy i
love those questions and i love your
support and i love your little voice
board as well um and i love your family
i love where you live so enjoy your life
hi kelly i'm juanita mora i'm an
allergist immunologist in chicago first
generation mexican american and i am
your super fan i'm an allergist
immunologist and in this pandemic i have
kept my doors open and helped a
community that was in dire need for help
to navigate this pandemic i was able to
keep my doors open and see essential
workers who were getting infected and
honestly it's been one of the most
rewarding things i have ever done in my
entire life
okay wait i like juanita so much her
story is so cool so i want to actually
surprise her
and actually just call her she has no
idea so hopefully it's a good surprise
[Music]
i'm such a fan of yours i loved your
videos so i wanted to actually be able
to talk to you myself so wait this is
awesome i need you to tell me about your
clinic and like what you're doing
thank you kelly i mean such a pleasure
to meet you
nice to meet you too so what what's up
with your clinic what are you doing well
you know i've been um at the chicago
allergy center opened my my own clinic
seven years ago and i was blessed kelly
to maintain my doors open
to help my community throughout this
pandemic and also to treat essential
workers that were getting infected
and um i was named the u.s news and
world report health hero
because of my work
with the latino immigrant community and
for that you know i am super blessed
nice to be here talking to you kelly oh
my god no what you're doing is amazing i
i want to know that what's next you know
for for your work with your community
what's next for you vaccinating the kids
kelly it's so important get them to that
christmas where we can listen to your cd
and yeah keep it protected
no that's so great it's beautiful what
you're doing and so great for your
community um thank you so much like
you're a true inspiration i i loved your
story so i wanted to be able to talk to
myself and i also i want i want to know
what your question is because
everybody's had a question so far so
like what's your question
oh of course kelly well first of all let
me tell you that you've uplifted not
only me but so many people throughout
this pandemic
you have brought us so much joy with the
kelly clarkson show with your music you
have let us you know get through this so
strong and because of that i have to
thank you
and you know i would unwind my day after
a full day of really hard work and come
and watch your show and laugh
and like sing along really
so my question to you is kelly you've
uplifted so many people throughout this
pandemic what is the one lesson that you
would take away
and what would you teach your children
when you from what you've learned
you know what's interesting i think the
answer to that is is
the same for if i was in a global
pandemic or not i think balance is so
hard especially when you're a working
single parent it's just it's or if
you're just a parent in general um if
you've got two of them it's still hard i
think a lot of people were reminded but
like in the isolating times like man we
don't see our family enough or maybe we
work like way too much i feel like
america is like
not as good as like europe in the sense
of like how they really take time for
their themselves and like their family
and their health and their mental health
and everything like that so i think
there's something to be learned there
for all of us um
now having a five and seven-year-old
they will
they will help you they stay honest
because i don't i'm never on my phone at
home and you know whenever i work i work
whenever i'm i'm home we're
we're doing legos we're doing all the
other stuff like we're we're doing that
kind of stuff and we're hanging so um
but what y'all are doing is it is
amazing and and it's been like you just
said you were helping people like on the
front lines the people that were getting
infected that's i think everybody you
know we've all been reminded like how
essential you know all these workers all
these nurses all these doctors are in
our lives like we i think we took
advantage of it and took for granted um
you know how lucky we are it was good to
be reminded of all that so thank you so
for all that you're doing like in your
community it's so cool there there are
other little angels like you in other
communities out there too doing this and
it's so cool and you're so awesome that
i want to invite you to come to my show
will you come to my show
kelly it would be a nightmare yes yes
okay
i want to hug you in person
you're my idol oh my god
oh thank you so much goodbye girl
all right thank you so much for the
questions guys and thank you so much for
the support and the kindness and
remember be so kind to yourself as well
and to your family and and have grace
for people and just have a really good
time with your family this you know
during the holiday season and thank you
so much for once again just your support
for the last 20 years i appreciate it
[Music]
you